meine damen und herren wir haben heute
im präsidium noch einmal sehr sorgfältig
über den gestrigen wahltag gesprochen
und seine konsequenzen für uns ist ganz
klar dass daraus ein auftrag abgeleitet
werden muss dass wir jetzt uns bemühen
eine regierung zu bilden eine regierung
getragen von den parteien die die wahl
gewonnen haben das ist die spd mit einem
sehr erheblichen zuwachs an stimmen das
sind die grünen und das ist die fdp und
wir werden deshalb auch mit allen
versuchen gemeinsam diesen weg zu
beschreiten
es hat in deutschland eine sehr
erfolgreiche sozial-liberale koalition
gegeben von 1969 bis 82 übrigens damals
aus einer großen koalition heraus wenn
man das noch erinnern darf und wie die
brand ist dann 69 kanzler geworden
helmut schmidt meistern den zweiten teil
dieser zeit und wir haben eine sehr gute
regierungszeit mit den grünen gehabt und
auch das ist eine sache die wir uns noch
gut erinnern jetzt gewissermaßen eine
sozial-ökologische liberale koalition zu
bilden hat also
grundlagen in der geschichte der
regierungstätigkeit in deutschland und
ist auch genau das was man tun muss wenn
man jetzt dafür sorgen will dass in
deutschland die zukunftsaufgaben
aufgegriffen werden die vor uns stehen
dazu zählt also zum beispiel dafür zu
sorgen dass wir mehr respekt in dieser
gesellschaft haben dass wir die
industrielle modernisierung dieses
landes hinbekommen und den
menschengemachten klimawandel aufhalten
große aufgaben denen wir uns stellen
wollen und über die wir gerne mit den
beiden anderen parteien ins gespräch
kommen wollen um dann so schnell wie
möglich auch tatsächlich eine regierung
zu bilden
das werden wir den gremien empfehlen im
übrigen haben wir noch mal gesehen dass
die erfolge in mecklenburg-vorpommern
und in berlin eben doch auch das noch
mal zusätzlich unterstreichen was wir
hier gesehen haben am wahltag die
bürgerinnen und bürger wünschen sich ein
regierungswechsel und sie wollen auch
dass wir die regierung führen in
deutschland in berlin und in wittenburg
vorpommern
wenn man sich die ergebnisse insgesamt
noch einmal anschaut dann sieht man
übrigens dass wir in vielen ländern dazu
gewonnen haben dass die spd auch in see
bevölkerungsreichen ländern stärkste
partei geworden ist bei den mandaten und
war den zweitstimmen etwas ganz ganz
besonderes und insofern fühlen wir uns
gesondert aufgerufen jetzt aus dem
auftrag den die wählerinnen und wähler
uns gegeben haben sehr bescheiden und
mit großer professionalität und ganz
pragmatisch ein gutes ergebnis zu machen
alle parteien die hier erfolge bei der
wahl hatten sind parteien die schon
miteinander regiert haben in der
geschichte die es gegenwärtig tun in
einzelnen bundesländern und klar ist
auch dass niemand an dem votum der
wähler novelle ohne schaden vorbeigehen
kann und das ist schon sehr deutlich
dass viele sich wünschen dass wir diese
nächste regierung bilden wir freuen uns
auf ihre zahlreichen fragen
morgens stolz die frage ist dann sieht
wie er spielt von der neuen osnabrücker
zeitung herr scholz was sagen sie dazu
dass die grünen und die fdp jetzt erst
einmal untereinander sprechen möchten
und wenn sie noch eine persönliche frage
erlauben wie lange haben sie heute nacht
geschlafen und was war ihr erster
gedanke beim aufwachen danke
erstmal ist es völlig okay wenn auch
diejenigen mit denen wir
zusammenarbeiten wollen untereinander
sprechen ich möchte eine regierung
bilden die auf vertrauen beruht der
parteien untereinander das muss ja darum
gehen dass man nicht nur die aufgaben
bewältigt über die man sich in einem
koalitionsvertrag verständigt sondern
auch die vielen aufgaben die auf einen
zukommen die man am anfang gar nicht
erkennen kann auch die letzten jahre der
regierung waren immer davon geprägt dass
wir neue dinge zu bewältigen hatten die
sich nicht abgezeichnet hatten während
der koalitionsbildung insofern geht es
schon darum dass das gut läuft ich finde
es gibt auch einen grundsatz der ganz
wichtiges regierungsparteien müssen
einander vertrauen sie müssen
miteinander zusammenarbeiten wollen und
nicht gewissermaßen immer hinten herum
erzählen was die anderen alles schlecht
machen die schwarz-gelbe koalition ist
sicherlich in den letzten jahren das
abschreckende beispiel für
regierungstätigkeit gewesen weil das
vertrauen zwischen cdu csu und fdp
überhaupt nicht existiert hat ich glaube
daran erinnern sich auch viele in der
fdp noch sehr genau wie schlecht das
auch für sie von seiten der cdu csu
damals gelaufen ist und deshalb sollte
es hier ganz anders sein ich finde eine
regierung die sich gebildet hat muss
auch so miteinander regieren dass sie
sich zutraut auch wiedergewählt zu
werden auch das wäre für mich ein guter
grundsatz
ansonsten habe ich gut geschlafen und
ich bin aufgewacht habe noch mal geguckt
ob irgendwas passiert ist was sich beim
einschlafen nicht zur kenntnis nehmen
konnte und habe mich dann noch mal
gefreut
ja mein name ist okay ich bin von der
finnischen zeitung helsingin sanomat
im europäischen ausland interessiert man
sich unter anderem dafür wie die nächste
deutsche regierung was was die nächste
deutsche regierung vom gemeinsamen
schulden hält nun bei manchen
sogenannten sparsamen mit riesen dann
hat man sogar angst von der sogenannten
schuldenunion was ist nun ihre position
jetzt nach der bundestagswahl als
möglicher nächster kanzler
ich glaube dass die sozialdemokratischen
regierungschef innen und der
regierungschef in den skandinavischen
ländern und der künftige regierungschef
in norwegen das ist sich alle freunde
darüber dass die spd diese wahl gewonnen
hat jedenfalls ist das was ich von allen
als botschaft bekommen habe vielleicht
noch einmal zu einer aussage zur frage
wie geht es da weiter wir haben eine
große kraftanstrengung unternommen um
die krise zu bekämpfen in europa das
haben wir gemeinsam getan nun ist ja
bisher noch nicht so viel geld geflossen
aus für die ersten maßnahmen die für
dieses kurzarbeiter programm in europa
auf den weg gebracht haben und für die
mittelstands kredite der europäischen
investitionsbank
sondern die mittel für den wiederaufbau
form sind ja im wesentlichen in aussicht
gestellt aber allein die tatsache dass
wir das gemacht haben hat dazu
beigetragen dass sich die konjunktur in
europa erholt dass kein staat
schwierigkeiten mit seiner
staatsfinanzierung bekommen hat schon
etwas ganz ganz besonderes
trotzdem gehört zu den verständigung die
wir dort getroffen haben erster die
union nimmt dafür kredite auf zweitens
sie werden zurückgezahlt bis 2058 darauf
habe ich bestanden dass das auch
festgelegt und wann es wird und wann es
spätestens beginnt und drittens zur
finanzierung werden wir auch kopien
resources schaffen also ich glaube
die skandinavischen länder werden sehr
glücklich sein über das was wir
miteinander machen in europa es geht um
starkes souveränes europa neue welt die
nicht einfacher wird
im raume von der rheinischen post herr
scholz werden sie in den
koalitionsverhandlungen
punkte nennen die für die spd und für
sie persönlich unverhandelbar sind oder
sagen sie wir gehen ergebnisoffen dort
hinein
und stellen alles als verhandlungsmasse
ein und frau gefahr eine frage an sie
bitte sie könnten ja jetzt mit einer
ampel in berlin eine gute vorlage für
ihren kanzlerkandidaten liefern wie
stehen sie denn zu diesem projekt
die spd hat ein programm aufgestellt das
kann jeder lesen wir alle haben das auf
vielen marktplätzen in deutschland an
vielen infoständen bei vielen haustür
besuchen vertreten und das will ich noch
mal sagen das hat ja zu diesem ergebnis
geführt dass wir da stehen wo wir jetzt
stehen es ein gemeinsames ergebnis der
ganzen spd und sind alle 400.000
mitglieder aktiv gewesen aber es hat
auch eine wirklich gute und
funktionierende zusammenarbeit gegeben
in der ganzen führung die beiden
parteivorsitzenden der generalsekretär
der fraktionsvorsitz und ich haben uns
engst abgestimmt schon lange bevor sie
wussten dass ich der kanzlerkandidat
werde wussten wir das miteinander und
das ist ein zeichen dafür wie gut das
funktioniert hat und die bürgerinnen
bürger haben jetzt weit über ein jahr
gesehen dass das geklappt hat und können
sich darauf verlassen dass dieses
gemeinsame management einer so großen
aufgabe für eine so traditionsreiche
demokratische partei und im hinblick auf
die anforderungen die wir in
verantwortung für unser land zu erfüllen
haben auch in zukunft gut klappen wird
aber dazu gehört auch dass wir jetzt
koalitionsverhandlung nicht in der
öffentlichkeit führen ich glaube es
gehört zu den guten stil dass man nicht
in lauter durch gesteckten papieren
lesen kann was gewissermaßen der eine
von dem anderen denkt sondern dass es
wirklich vertrauensvoll zur kooperation
kommt ich halte also nichts davon und
wir alle darauf war haben wir uns
verständigt dass wir jetzt irgendwie
einzelne punkte mit ihnen sorgfältig
durch diskutieren das machen wir mit den
freunden mit denen wir regieren wollen
in berlin kann ich mich da anschließend
es ist so dass wir verschiedene
möglichkeiten haben für eine koalition
hier in der hauptstadt definitiv wird
die koalition und der
sozialdemokratischer führung arbeiten
und wir werden in den gremien besprechen
was funktionieren kann wie wir die
möglichst großen schnittmengen haben mit
dem programm das wir als
sozialdemokraten in berlin beschlossen
haben und natürlich kann eine
möglichkeit die im bund erfolgreich ist
die übrigens auch in rheinland-pfalz er
erfolgreich ist auch ein weg für berlin
sein aber nochmal wir müssen das in den
gremien besprechen und wir werden mit
allen gespräche führen und dann den
besten weg für die stadt auch ausloten
frage an sehr stolz wie groß ist denn
ihre erleichterung darüber dass ein
linksbündnis aufgrund der schwäche der
linkspartei überhaupt nicht mehr möglich
ist es gab ja doch einige in der spd
sich die sich das gewünscht hätten es
gibt nun auch befürchtungen dass
christian lindner die preise hochtreiben
könnte weil eben die drohkulisse
linksbündnis nicht mehr steht und
vielleicht eine zweite frage an sie oder
auch an herrn walter borjans
verhandlungen mit der fdp steuerpolitik
ist das für sie der größte brocken ist
das die größte schwierigkeit wo man sich
annähern muss
da vielleicht darf ich kurz zu sagen
ärmlich auf die inhaltlichen punkte gilt
das was ich eben schon gesagt hat für
uns alle gemeinsam
wir werden jetzt nicht mit ihnen die
einzelne details künftiger
koalitionsgespräche durch erörtern
verstehe dass sie alles genau verstehen
wollen aber wir wollen vertrauensvoll
mit denen reden mit denen wir uns
zusammentun wollen und was das
wahlergebnis betrifft haben wir immer
vor der wahl gesagt es macht gar keinen
sinn
spekulationen darüber anzustellen was
nach der wahl möglich sein wird denn es
ist demokratie die bürgerinnen und
bürger entscheiden sie beschließen auch
mit dem gewichtigen dass sie den
einzelnen parteien geben welche
regierungen möglich sind und welcher
auftrag daraus erwächst und der auftrag
den wir bekommen haben von den w lan und
wlan und er ist sehr eindeutig eine
regierung zusammen mit grünen und fdp zu
bilden und das wollen wir jetzt auch
ich will vielleicht du noch dazu sagen
dass in der gegenwärtigen situation olaf
scholz hat das gesagt vertrauen das
wichtigste ist um
in einer regierungskoalition zusammen zu
kommen die auch bestand haben soll und
deswegen finde ich das von allen seiten
rote linien die über die medien dem
anderen zugespielt werden ein kleines
fenster schließen dass wir eine
gemeinsame grundlage wichtig wäre und
deswegen finde ich wir sind alle gut
beraten das gilt aber dann für alle
seiten dass wir aufeinander zugehen und
ausloten was für dieses land wichtig ist
und das ist vor allem dass es ein
aufbruch gibt der gerecht ist aber der
eben auch kräfte freisetzt und ich
glaube da gibt es eine ganze reihe von
punkten über die man sehr konstruktiv
miteinander reden kann
das schon britischen fernsehen schon von
mir eine frage auf englisch gestatten
last
selection
nicht mehr aus zu der second question
first
of labour ist part of the opinion
very hard convince the british motto
lief die jungen
hauptproblem scamming von
dudley
first mai die
sbb barry fast and getting results for
government and eight people for
christmas is possible
und der rentner germany uss cole in
government aid
[Musik]
demokratie ohne opposition
ausnahmsweise mit einer frage auf
deutsch
herr scholz können sie uns ein bisschen
was verraten zu den formaten in denen
sie mit den anderen parteien sprechen
möchten also zum einen wie schnell soll
das passieren inwiefern erstmal auch
bilateral oder eben gleich mit 1 3 und
wie groß sollten verhandlungsgruppen
sein wir werden sehr schnell mit den
anderen parteien mit denen wir eine
regierung bilden wollen
uns abstimmen über gesprächs verläufe
ich glaube dass es sondierungen nicht so
lange geben sollte sondern dass man
einfach sich schnell
einmal
bespricht und dann auch eine
entscheidung trifft und dann auch
richtig in koalitionsverhandlungen geht
die dann auch zu ergebnissen führen ich
jedenfalls
glaube dass man sage ich habe jedenfalls
hab mir immer mühe gegeben verhandlungen
so zu führen dass man auch ergebnisse
erzielt die funktionieren für alle drei
parteien für die anhängerschaften und in
diesem fall auch für das land das muss
man immer dazu sagen denn jede partei
hat ja erwartungen die viele menschen
mit ihrer stimmabgabe für diese partei
verbinden geweckt und das muss ja zu
einem guten ergebnis geführt werden wo
alle anhängerschaften sagen das gefällt
mir das ist gut dass sie das gemacht
haben und das will ich noch versuchen
hinzukriegen
wie sega rtl n tv eine frage an frau
gefallen wie bewerten sie denn den
ausgang des berliner volksentscheids zum
thema deutsche wohnen enteignen und wie
dicke denken sie sich diesem votum dann
in zukunft zu stellen ich habe mich
haben wahlkampf sehr klar positioniert
dass sich enteignung oder
vergesellschaftung nicht für den
richtigen weg halte um die frage des
bezahlbaren wohnens zu lösen wir haben
dennoch jetzt einen volksentscheid der
positiv ausgegangen ist wir müssen als
politik damit verantwortungsvoll und
respektvoll umgehen dass die schritte
die jetzt einzuleiten sind müssen
eingeleitet werden aber ich finde es
muss eine sehr ernsthafte prüfung geben
über rechtmäßigkeit verfassungsmäßigkeit
finanzierbarkeit und die folgen die das
für das land berlin auch hat und in
dieser abwägung müssen wir am ende
entscheiden was wirklich getan werden
kann um mit diesem appell ist es ja
keinen gesetzentwurf sondern ein appell
an die politik umzugehen ich glaube
wesentlich ist dass wir das tun was
nötig ist um das problem zu lösen und
das wohnungsneubau es ist ganz klar der
schutz der mieterinnen und mieter im
bestand aber wir haben in berlin das
ziel im jahr 20.000 wohnungen zu bauen
natürlich auch bezahlbaren wohnraum das
entspricht auch dem was natürlich oder
40 auf bundesebene vorgenommen hat wir
müssen die große soziale frage des
bezahlbares wohnen wohnens lösen und das
heißt wohnungsneubau in größenordnung
und ein starkes bündnis zwischen den
städtischen gesellschaften den
genossenschaften aber auch den privaten
nur dann werden wir das hinbekommen
zwei fragen einen herrn scholz und einer
an herrn walter borjans schulz armin
laschet hat gerade im ruf der cdu
bekanntgegeben dass er gestern bereits
mit christian lindner gesprochen hat und
das heute mit annalena baerbock tun wird
gibt es dazu auch pläne auf seiten der
spd was gespräche angeht und an herrn
beider borjans sie sagten gerade rote
linien können störend sein heißt dass
man ist auch bereit zugeständnisse zu
machen gerade auch gegenüber vielleicht
der fdp
also ich bin nicht mitglied des
bundesvorstands der union des weiß ich
nicht was da stattfindet aber einige von
ihnen sind ja embedded wie ich so
mitkriege wenn ich den ticker meldungen
folgen darf unabhängig davon natürlich
gibt es kontakte und im übrigen werden
wir das jetzt ja auch nach den
beschlüssen die wir jetzt geführt haben
ganz formal auch konkret betreiben es
geht darum den wunsch der wählerinnen
und wähler umzusetzen und das werden wir
mit aller ruhe und klarheit vorantreiben
und ich glaube dass auch alle verstehen
dass da eine botschaft mit der wahl und
dem wahltag verbundenes die man nicht
überhören darf
ja ich glaube die das wahlergebnis
gestern abend hat eines ganz deutlich
gemacht es gibt nur eine konstellation
von gewinn an die die künftige regierung
bilden können und das ist
die ampel oder wie wir sagen auch die
rheinland- pfalz lösungen und aus diesem
grund finde ich muss klar sein dass man
sich an einen tisch setzt dass man auf
augenhöhe miteinander verhandelt die spd
hat als stärkste kraft in dieser
konstellation den auftrag zur regierung
die stimmung und die stimmen waren einen
deutlich stimmen für einen kanzler olaf
scholz und auf der grundlage sprechen
miteinander untersucht man natürlich die
gemeinsamkeit und die besteht nicht
darin dass man als erstes erstmal alles
von allen anderen ausschließt und sich
damit anschließend wieder verabschiedet
also wir haben den festen willen eine
stabile auf vertrauen gegründete
regierung zu bilden der die eindeutig
als wahlgewinner aus dieser wahl
hervorgegangen sind
die frage scholz erstmal herzlichen
glückwunsch zu ihrem wahlergebnis die
frage stelle ich so wie stellen sie sich
vor in die zukunft die
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit mit
russland und der ukraine
ich komme von russischsprachigen
fernsehsender aus berlin deswegen die
frage
die zukunft europas wird auch davon
geprägt werden dass es eine gelingt eine
gute zusammenarbeit zwischen der
europäischen
union und ihren nachbarn dann ländern
zustande zu bringen dazu gehört im
übrigen aber dass alle gut akzeptieren
dass es den weiteren fortschritt der
integration der europäischen union gibt
einer gesellschaft mit
freiheitsrechten mit liberalität eine
offene gesellschaft mit marktwirtschaft
und sozialstaatlichen traditionen und
ich glaube das ist dann die grundlage
dafür dass das gelingt in europa das die
voraussetzung dafür immer auch bedeuten
dass wir die kriterien die wir über
gemeinsame sicherheit in europa gefunden
haben ganz in der tradition von willy
brandt und helmut schmidt auch in
zukunft beachtet werden müssen ist klar
eine der ganz wichtigen sachen für gute
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit ist immer
die anerkennung der unverletzlichkeit
der grenzen das gehörte zu den damaligen
prozessen von ksc und osze dazu und das
muss auch heute bestand haben
guten morgen herr schuld gibt es bereits
einen vorschlag für den spd
fraktionsvorsitzende im presidio oder im
vorstand besprochen worden wäre wie es
die cdu die union hat das jahr vertagt
vertrag die spd auch die entscheidung
erst mal und die zweite frage es gab vor
der wahl bereits bestrebungen einen
mitgliederentscheid über einen
eventuellen koalitionsvertrag
herbeizuführen wie stehen sie dazu also
wir haben einen formalen vorschlag noch
nicht gemacht aber wir sind uns alle
einig dass der jetzige
fraktionsvorsitzende ein ganz toller
mann ist und ich glaube dass seine
fraktion auch alle so rolf mützenich ist
ein ausstand ein ganz wichtiger baustein
für unser gemeinsames gebäude gewesen
und ohne ihnen hätten die
parteivorsitzenden ich der
generalsekretär das gar nicht geschafft
diese große linie über so lange zeit zu
entwickeln also ein guter mann und den
brauchen wir da und die zweite frage ist
wir werden jetzt erst mal gespräche
führen und alle anderen entscheidungen
treffen wir wenn es soweit ist
bern
eine
ja hallo jan dörner stück oder zeitungen
ich meine frage an fressen fressen wie
sehen sie denn jetzt die aussichten
zusammen mit der fdp und den grünen zu
reagieren
können sie sich das gut vorstellen
sie haben im wahlkampf immer von einer
progressiven regierung gesprochen die
gebildet werden soll könnte die ampel
das seien
eine progressive regierung wie ich sie
mir vorstelle die markiert tatsächlich
in den aufbruch für deutschland ich
glaube dass wir auch in der zeit stehen
diese unten aufruf verlangt in vielen
fragen im bewältigen des klimawandels in
der gestaltung der digitalisierung und
vielen anderen fragen die wir in unserem
zukunftsprogramm aufgeschrieben haben
wir müssen nach vorne gehen und das war
immer meine überzeugung dass wir dazu
auch parteien brauchen die sich zum
einen vertrauen die zum anderen aber
auch in den auftrag von wählerinnen und
wählern haben wir haben jetzt drei
parteien es ist schon gesagt worden die
gestern in den zugewinn verbuchen
konnten die spd steht mit ihrem so
gewinn ganz vorne und wir freuen uns
sehr auf die zusammenarbeit und auf die
gespräche die jetzt anstehen
guten tag ich bin auf sesseln
technischer fahren seien
besser prinzip an für sie wichtig sind
dahin außenpolitik in
koalitionsverhandlungen und da
möchten sie dass zwei mitarbeiter
beginnt
für die außenpolitik deutschlands gilt
auf alle fälle das für uns ein
gemeinsames handeln der europäischen
union
die grundlage für all das ist was wir in
den nächsten jahren tun müssen die welt
wird bald zehn milliarden einwohner
haben es wird viele mächte geben nicht
nur die usa china und russland sondern
auch andere länder das wieder
aufgestiegen asiens korea japan vietnam
indonesien malaysia indien um einige zu
nennen es wird auch starke länder aus
afrika oder dem süden amerikas geben die
in 20 30 jahren relevant sein werden in
der welt und wenn wir das was uns
wichtig ist ein rechtsstaat demokratie
marktwirtschaft und sozialstaat auch an
technologischer fortschrittlichkeit
sichern wollen dann geht das nur
gemeinsam in der europäischen union und
die ist deshalb immer ein wichtiges
datum darum glaube ich auch dass dort
schon eine besondere herausforderung hat
als das große land mitten in der
europäischen union mit seiner großen
bevölkerung und seiner großen
wirtschaftskraft es zur eigenen
nationalen sache zu machen dass der
fortschritt der europäischen union
gelingt das ist eine gute kooperation
gibt zwischen ost und west in der eu
zwischen nord und süd dass niemand
versucht die union zu dominieren sondern
dass das eine gemeinsame gute
perspektive wird dazu gehört auch dass
wir politisch relevant sein müssen wo
die bürgern und bürger politische
relevanz verlangen und wir sollten all
denjenigen widerstehen die von uns herum
und da sind ganz schön viele
versuchungen zurückzukehren in die
zeiten des 17 18 und 19 jahrhunderts mit
der idee als ob man direkt was macht mit
den großen ländern
europas deutschland frankreich england
und russland und alle anderen gucken zu
nein das was wir als fortschritt
erreicht haben ist dass die europäische
union zusammen wächst und wir werden
dafür sorgen dass sie eine besser server
union wird das ist ein wichtiges merkmal
für die politik die ich mir für die
zukunft vorgestellt habe und was die
frage dieses gas
pipeline projekt betrifft das ist ja nun
fertiggestellt und es geht darum dass
jetzt alle dafür sorgen dass die
garantien die mit dem betrieb verbunden
sind auch akzeptiert werden zu den
garantien gehört dass die ukraine
transit land bleibt und dass wir
sicherstellen dass nicht der gast die
gasversorgung einiger länder im osten
europas zum beispiel gefährdet wird von
russland aus weil sie sagen dass sie
diese strukturen nicht mehr bedienen
wollen und das ist etwas worauf sich
alle verlassen können das haben wir sehr
ernst gemeint und dafür haben wir uns
auch sehr eingesetzt
der englische
specialist bei den teen challenge china
will be to the
united states the transatlantic
partnership ist office sfo rassen
germany
das important to work together
to have konflikten banorte kosten
vielleicht darf ich wenn die fragerunde
zu ende ist noch mal sagen was wir
eingangs gesagt haben es gibt gute
tradition auf die wir zurückgreifen
können es hat eine sozialliberale
regierung gegeben rot-gelb es hat eine
sozial-ökologische regierung gegeben rot
grün und wenn wir daran anknüpfen dann
kann etwas gutes gelingen am beginn der
20er jahre für unser land denn das ist
doch etwas sehr bemerkenswert es gibt
drei parteien in deutschland die eine
jeweils eigene fortschritts erzählung
haben die vorstellung wie fortschritt in
deutschland gelingen kann die
sozialdemokratische partei hat eine
solche vorstellung die wir mit unseren
programmen und mit dem wofür wir in der
wahl geworben haben vorgestellt haben
die grünen haben eine da spielt der das
aufhalten des klimawandels genauso wie
bei uns und bei anderen eine rolle aber
es ist dort sehr sehr sehr zentral aber
es ist eine fortschritts erzählung und
eine fortschritts erzählung für eine
moderne gesellschaft gibt es auch bei
der fdp wenn also drei parteien die den
fortschritt am beginn der 20er jahre im
blick haben sich zusammentun dann kann
das etwas gutes werden selbst wenn sie
dafür unterschiedliche ausgangslagen
haben und das konstruktiv zusammen zu
führen das ist das was wir hier
gemeinsam auf den weg bringen wollen und
wo wir ein mandat der bürgerinnen und
bürger sehen das auch ernsthaft
voranzutreiben schönen dank